- [Dominic] It's a rarity to
go to a rollerskating rink
and find live music there.
- [Narrator] Most other roller
rinks have gone digital.
But head to Southern California,
and you'll find one of
the last remaining rinks
to employ a live organ player.
(funky music)
- My name is Dominic Cangelosi,
and I own the Moonlight Rollerway.
I've been playing rollerskating
music for 70 years.
There are only about 10 or 15
roller rink organists left in the country.
In the ‘40s and ‘50s, most of
the rinks around the country
used live organ music,
and then when Elvis
Presley and the Beatles
all came into the picture
in the ‘50s and ‘60s,
most of the rinks around the country
phased out the live organ
to play recorded music.
- [Narrator] But not
the Moonlight Rollerway.
Wednesday through Monday,
the Moonlight Rollerway
plays recorded music, just
like most roller rinks.
But one day a week,
Dominic gets to dust off
his Hammond organ, and throw
back to a different time.
(organ music)
- [Dominic] On Tuesdays, I
play from 8 o’clock 'til 10:30.
The people that come on Tuesday
nights are a mixed crowd.
A number of the skaters
are old-time skaters
in their 70s and 80s who like
to skate to the organ music.
This place is special because
it's been here for so long.
It's a historical landmark.
People have skated here through the years,
met their boyfriends, girlfriends here.
Raised a family, bring
their grandchildren.
And it's something from the past
that I just want to hold on
to at least one night a week.
I love coming here, I come every day.
And I enjoy my customers.
They appreciate it and
they like the music.
I have no plans to stop playing the organ.
I'll play it as long as I'm here.
Thank you for coming, and
hope to see you all real soon.
Goodnight.
(electronic tone)